hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about the two main causes of
hair-loss
okay number one its nutritional
deficiency and number two it has nothing
to do with nutrition it's a hormone
problem okay but this idea of taking
shampoo or conditioner that has B
vitamins or collagen to somehow I think
that's going to absorb in your hair and
do any good it really doesn't work you
have to take it orally or make sure
you're not deficient okay so so let's
talk about first about the vitamin
deficiencies that occur with hair and it
could be multiple but you can have a
vitamin C deficiency vitamin C is in all
the leafy greens vitamin C helps
collagen hair is a collagen it's a type
of collagen is called keratin it's like
a fibrous real tough collagen so you
also need trace minerals this one is
really really important in the
manufacturing of protein in the body if
you want hair skin nails arteries bone
okay so we need the trace minerals for
that especially your muscles so trace
minerals are those minerals needed in
very small amounts unfortunately they're
not in our foods because they're not in
our soil anymore so unless you're
consuming like sea kelp or some type of
trace mineral blend you're not going to
have it in your diet and that is a big
reason for hair loss
okay now excellent collagen so the type
of collagen that someone needs to regrow
their hair is is a type 1 and type 3
okay so that would be the type of
collagen that you would need to support
that and then silica silica is an
interesting element and you don't want
to get it you want to get this in a like
a food base or an herb like a plant base
okay horse tail the plant called horse
tail is loaded with silica but silica is
kind of like the probably most abundant
elements in the body it helps in the
manufacturing of collagen hair nails
skin it makes it very very shiny and
tough and very healthy and prevents
wrinkles makes your nails really strong
makes the hair from protected against
splitting and then you have the B
vitamins it's interesting with B
vitamins and the trace minerals work
with a lot of skin problems a lot of
hair problems because if you're
deficient with the vitamins your hair is
going to fall out okay
specifically biotin and some of the
other B vitamins okay what the best way
to get to B vitamins is through
nutritional yeast okay get them from
nutritional yeast so that we all the
vitamin deficiencies that you could have
- that could create hair loss all right
now you also have alopecia with this
autoimmune problem and you also have
male pattern baldness or receding hair
that is high levels of DHT DHT is a very
powerful testosterone and what happens
there's an enzyme in your body that
converts testosterone into this powerful
DHT - an enzyme called 5-alpha reductase
just in case you wanted to know that and
if you get a an enzyme inhibitor like
stinging nettle root it's called
stinging nettle root which is one of the
top ones that I recommend that will
reduce DHT okay and that helps or Monali
like to get your hair back it's also
good for prostate it's also good for a
facial hair okay so it's and it's also
good for acne all right so now I
actually have a product that has every
single one of these ingredients in it
and you can get more information below
if you're interested but the trace
minerals are a plant base the collagen
is wild-caught fish skin guys type 1 and
type 3 the silica is from horsetail okay
which is a plant base and the biotin is
not excessively high like a lot of times
people buy up the biotin in like 10,000
IU's and then they start getting other
side effects like acne that's because
they're not getting divided the B
vitamins in the natural complex so I
actually have biotin and the B vitamins
in the natural complex so you won't get
other side effects and then I put this
thing in
to actually lower the DHT and it has a
food based vitamin C so you can check it
out this link down below if you're
interested but I just wanted to kind of
cover it's real simple if you just plug
in nutrition if that's what it is or if
you have alopecia or male pattern
baldness you would want to add the
stinging other roots so thank you so
much for watching hey guys thank you so
much for watching please click the
subscribe button and I will see you in
the next video